bonjour laurent cesari merci d'être avec
nous cet après midi sur rt france alors
on a longuement parlé de cette rencontre
entre les deux chefs d'état première
question que peut-on attendre de cette
rencontre justement comme on le dit tout
à l'heure qui avait pas de de grandes
choses spectaculaires à attendre c'est
juste mais je pense qu'on ne peut
attendre ce présumé par une pelle froide
aussi bien les etats-unis que la russie
ont intérêt incertaine si la
déstabilisation des relations de la
russie pour éviter de faire trop de
dépenses d'armement et les états unis
parce que manifestement là comment dire
la chose qui préoccupe le plus
by dane actuellement c'est c'est la
chine
donc on peut s'attendre à une certaine
normalisation dans dans certains
domaines par exemple les les
cyberattaques même si aura pas des
changes comme ceux qui rappellent les
échanges et d'espions à l'époque de la
guerre froide ou bien encore une reprise
de la négociation sur la ligne bleue
l'arrêt du la limitation des armements
stratégiques voir sur le climat à
laurence hézard et vous vous parliez à
l'instant de la chine est ce que la
chine veut justement à être un sujet de
convergence pour pour les pour les deux
présidents et si oui à quelles
pourraient être les axes de la
discussion autour de la chine
ben je ne sais pas trop si elle peut
être un axe de convergence pense que
manifestement actuellement géré la chine
est l'adversaire désigné et des états
unis
et en ce qui concerne la russie il ya
une forte coopération militaire
actuellement avec la chine on pourrait
dire qu'actuellement vous avez un retour
à la configuration géopolitique
classique de guerre froide des
puissances et terrestres chine russie
contre contrôler les puissances les
puissants victimes donc là pour
l'instant j'avoue que je ne le vois pas
trop sur la sur la chine ce qui ferait à
se dire
john a qualifié vladimir poutine de
tueurs à la russie s'est récemment dit
avec les états unis était un pays
inamicale est ce que le dialogue est
vraiment possible entre les deux hommes
il dialogue si on attend une grande
convergence évidemment n'ont eu d'autre
mais d'autant que vahid elle mène une
politique qui ce qui se veut
relativement idéologiques fondées sur
des grands principes des mots démocratie
contre contre le pays
non non démocratique
mais après tout il y at il besoin de
deux d'être véritablement amis pour
collaborer nous je pense que je peux
attendre c'est un peu une une reprise de
à un moindre niveau peut-être de ce qu
était le dialogue merican aux
soviétiques de commentaire de la donne
avant la seconde guerre froide des
années des années 1960 une de soixante
dix est ce que cette cette rencontre un
peu aboutir justement on parlait de ses
points de convergence ou vous disiez
tout à l'heure c'était l'intérêt des
deux pays à 6,2 de coopérer quels sont
les points sur lesquels ces deux pays
pourraient et devraient coopérer comme
je vous disais d'une part vend tous les
armements nucléaires
il ya quand même que tu ne tout une
négociation à reprendre de sur le sur le
traité sur le traité
new start il a effectivement dire c est
prévu également comment dire là le le
programme nucléaire iranien
on voit bien quand même que la ligne de
la ligne de bae d'année plus chaud pour
la matière que celle de de trump et de
même encore là la réduction des les
attaques cybernétiques notamment des
demandes de rançon le le réchauffement
climatique
et puis dernier point extrêmement
important et d'ailleurs je crois que ça
sera ils veulent le faire l'un de
l'autre ils veulent bien faire
comprendre ce qui est pour eux
respectivement il admissible des
radiations avant de de se séparer de
rang cesari les etats unis ont refusé
l'idée d'une conférence de presse
commune à l'issue de cette rencontre
assad vladimir poutine s'exprimera
pourquoi cette décision de la part des
états unis
c'est parce que trouvé lors de la
conférence de presse de 2018 dont vous
avez parlé expliqué que dans la sphère
des à gérance russe dans l'élection
présidentielle it et le comment dire il
accordait davantage fois a ajouté nous
casser les services des renseignements
intérieurs je suis évidemment les
fonctionnaires américaine et puis pas
contre merci beaucoup laurent césar et
d'avoir été avec nous cet après midi sur
rt frange rappelle que vous êtes
professeur d'histoire contemporaine à
l'université d'arras merci beaucoup fois